well the hit tv series csi starts a
brand new chapter right here at home csi
vegas premieres tonight on channel 8.
and the show features the return of some
fan favorites arc omana is live in
henderson at a premiere party for the
series and arko you have a special guest
with you tonight right
well denise and brian there's a lot of
excitement about csi vegas the premiere
party here at fly pine henderson is
going to start in about an hour but
joining me live right now we have the
creator of the whole csi television
franchise anthony zeiker thank you so
much for joining us the the franchise
returns home to vegas what does that
mean to you it means everything in my
hometown is our fifth installment of csi
and to invite america in the world to
really be part of this great crime
franchise is just a joy
and being back in las vegas you know
what's the benefit of having a show like
this take place in las vegas well the
thing is look our franchise was built on
justice for victims and that's what our
show is all about what better way to
feature our hometown of las vegas to the
world in all its capacity and you know
great things happen here bad things
happen here but in the end justice is
served
and i know uh what can people expect
from the show
uh bigger upgrades fantastic csi shots a
brand new diversified cast william
peterson is back georgia fox is back uh
captain brass is back so if you're a fan
of the old show we got four people
coming back in a brand new cast to bring
us into the future for csi vegas yeah i
know there are some fan favorites like
we've been talking about returning uh
it's a mix of kind of what we know and
new surprises right absolutely we we're
going home with the characters we're
doing more character arts doing a 10
episode arc about the lab being
compromised so there's a lot of new
runway for this new series
awesome well anthony congratulations and
csi vegas premieres tonight only on
channel 8 starting at 10 p.m and it's
going to be a really exciting night and
denise one of our very own will actually
be featured on the show george knapp
will be in a couple of those episodes
yeah in fact orca we just heard about
that today do you have an idea of when
those episodes are going to be airing
yet denise the first episode george will
be in will air on october 20th so we'll
definitely be on the lookout for that
back to you all right debut tonight
george in two weeks from tonight all
right orco thanks for that